[موسيقى]
طبعا انا على الهوا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
ه ماريا مثل ما شافت بلش مثل ما بلشت
شخصيتها هي الانسانه اللي عمليه كثير بتحب
شغلها بتحب بيتها بتحب اهلها بتحب اللي
استعوت عليهم مغرومه بنور لانه هي الشخص
اللي وعيت عليه الحاله الدراميه تبع ماريا
بدها تتصعد اكثر لانه هي اذا بدك الضحيه
الوحيده بمسلسل الاخوه هي ماريا حنشوف
حاله مرضها لماريا تفاعلها مع المرض هال
المراه الجباره القويه اللي بعدها واقفه
حد امها حد بيا حد حبيبها اذا بدك بقى ه
الشخصيه من اول ما قريتها انا حسيت شو
بدها تعمل ومن هلا عم بقوللك رح يخلص
الاخوه وان شاء الله بخير وسلامه وكلنا
حنكون اشتغلنا بضمير بس ماريا بتخيل حتضل
حتضل عايشه بقلوب كثار يعني حتضل يمكن
حرقه بمحل بقلوب
كثار
جدا انا
حدا مسالمه لاخر حدود بس بنفس الوقت وبضحي
كثير حتى لو على حساب نفسي ولو على مصلحتي
مريه عن جد بتشبهني يمكن مرض بقول يا رب
تبعد عني ما امرض بس يمكن كنت كمان عملت
اخذت القرارات نف ماريا لا ماريا كثير انا
كثير حنونه وكثير عاطفيه بس انسانه انا
اكثر واقعيه يعني انا اقوى من ماريا ماريا
ضعيفه انا انسانه بالعكس انا ترك حدا بس
اذا حدا بده يفل دغري بفتح له الطريق ليفل
يعني اسهل للاشخاص اللي يعني اذا بدك
لشريك حياتي كثير سهله عنده انه يفل لانه
انا حدا دائما الواحد مهيئ له الطريق انه
يفل ما بتلقط بحدا يلي بده يبقى معي لانه
عن جد بده اياني ولانه بكل جوارحه بده
اياني ياما اذا في 1% عنده اي يشن
[موسيقى]
يفل ليك في كثير قصص بالحياه بتكون بحياتك
اولويه وما بتخلي عنها بتصيري شوي
دبلوماسيه بمطار لانه في شيء اهم العائله
الاولاد الاستمراريه المستقبل بتصيري نوعا
ما شوي دبلوماسيه مع مع الوقت بس اني اني
غير كل انا كيف معتقداتي او صعب انا حدا
صعب
[موسيقى]
شوي هي غيرتني لانه انا بعمري ال 17 سنه
كان عندي اول ولد بقى صرت انظر للمجتمع مع
نظره الام يعني ممكن حدا يزعجني او ياذيني
بطلع فيه انه هيدا عنده ام اذا انا زعلته
او قهرته امه حتزعل بقى من هيك صار عندي
هالنظره وهيدي عملت ف رافه كثير كبيره
وانا دائما بقول ربنا قدمني محلات انا حدا
قلت لك صعبه كثير عملني ام كانه ربنا عن
جد اعطاني هيدا الطفل بعمر صغير ل ليسهل
لي حياتي يعني يسهل حياتي للناس اللي
حوالي لانه من خلال اودي اليوم صت انا
انسانه كثير
مسالمه هذا ما كان عندي والام يعني ربنا
خلق فيها هي الحنان له
تكون يعني ليسلمها هي الاستمراريه بقى
اعطاها احساس فظيع تقدر تعطيه تقدر تضحي
لاخر الحدود لان الرجل ما بيقدر يعطي هذا
الحنان ما بيقدر يعطي ه التضحيه ما بقدر
محب يكون وعاطفه وال بدك اه بس بضل عنده
انانيه المراه ما في ما عندها انانيه لما
صير عندها ولد ن تقول
انا
اكيد بحب وانا قلت يعني حتى انا قلت انه
اذاذا بينعرض علي شخصيه تخلى عن عن هاللبس
الحلو والانيق والشعر والميك اب وهدا انه
يعني انا عملت شي مشابه لهذا الموضوع
بمسلسل اميليا اميليا هي ارمله ترملت
صغيره وعندها ولدين بتشتغل بالبيوت منها
مثقفه منها دارسه بدها تشتغل بالبيوت و
بالمكاتب تنظف لتعيش اولادها حتى بتشتغل
بمدرسه ولادها ابنها بون واقف بكب ورقه
كلينك بتلم وبحطها بالزباله بتنظف الملاعب
كان ما في مكياج ما في شعر اللبس كان
مبهدل اي انجيد يعني كثير انبسطت بالشخصيه
اللي لعبتها لانه حسيتها هالقد قريبه من
الارض قريبه من التراب بعيده عن التكلف
بعيده عن عن الشكل بعيده عن مننا سطحيه
عميقه جدا عميقه بقى لا انا بتمنى العب
هيك
[موسيقى]
ادوار اه في مواقف كثيره هلا بولاده من
الخاصره لما بحمل ابني بشنطه شقتين لي
اياه عمره بالاشهر هذا شي كان فظيع وقت
تموت وقت يموت بي بين ايدي هذا شي يعني في
مشاهد عمع انا بقيت على اسبوع ما عندي صوت
لانه بتفق السيطره بتنهار بتحطي حالك
بالموقف بتلاقي انه اصعب من انك انت تقدري
تتحمليه بقى تتقمص وتعطيه بدك تعيشيه صح
بمرق بحالات نحن كممثلين كثير صعبه من هيك
بقول انا وفعلا ثلاث ارباع الممثلين
بشتغلوا من جوع قلبهم تعبان لانه بالنهار
يعني بالمسلسل بيقطعوا بحالات مرهقه يعني
حتى وقت تروحي تسقطي ولد طيب انه هذا شي
كثير
بشع